[Music]
there are some people who go to great
lengths to look like their favorite
Disney characters and then there are
others who look like the animated
characters without even trying these
everyday people and celebs are the
carbon copies of some of the most
popular Disney Princesses princes heroes
and villains if you're new to our
channel don't forget to subscribe and
please give this video a big thumbs up
because today we're sharing 10 people
who twin with Disney characters by
accident ukrainian judge and ursula this
ukrainian judge is the spitting image of
one of Disney's most evil villains
her name is ala bandura and she's a dead
ringer for Ursula the half octopus half
woman character from The Little Mermaid
when this photo of the judge was posted
online many people couldn't help but
notice she look like Ursula's long-lost
twin sister with her dramatic eye makeup
her bright red lipstick and her black
and gray hair Ella and Ursula are
definitely twinning Lily Cole and Merida
there's a reason why everyone thinks
Lily Cole looks a lot like Merida from
brave the Disney Princess was actually
inspired by the English model and
actress when you look at photos of lily
and Merida side-by-side you can see how
much these two look just alike they both
have the same wild and untamed curly
hair the same pouty lips and the same
big and expressive eyes Joe Jonas and
Aladdin Joe Jonas stepped out on the red
carpet and accidentally twinned with the
Disney character Aladdin with his hair a
bit longer Joe looks like he and Aladdin
were separated at Birth they even have
the same thick eyebrows and the same big
brown eyes all Joe needs is a purple
vest and a pair of white harem pants to
really become Aladdin's doppelganger
twinning with flash from Zootopia you
probably never thought it would be
possible for a human to look exactly
like flash from Zootopia but boy were
you wrong this girl looks exactly like
the friendly and adorable character
right down to her goofy facial
expression and the shape of her eyes if
Zootopia ever makes it to Broadway this
girl should definitely play the role of
the lovable sloth Carl from ups twin
doesn't this guy look almost identical
to Carl Fredricksen from up is
the animated characters real-life twins
if we didn't know any better we would
think Carl was definitely created with
this man's image in mind they have the
same glasses the same nose the same wide
smile and the same bushy hair Chris
Hemsworth and John Smith back when actor
Chris Hemsworth was rocking a long and
full head of hair he was a dead ringer
for the character of John Smith in the
movie Pocahontas he may not be an
English explorer but Chris definitely
has the same blue eyes perfectly styled
hair and the same chiseled jawline as
John with a live-action remake of this
movie in the works Disney doesn't have
to look too far to cast Pocahontas his
love interest jaw Sarkozy and the prince
without even knowing it John Sarkozy is
twinning with the prince from Beauty and
the Beast John who's the son of the
former President of France is definitely
the princes look-alike they have the
same gorgeous head of hair the same face
shape and the exact same bushy eyebrows
the only difference is the color of
their hair but all John needs is a pair
of blue contact lenses to complete his
transformation into the Prince karela de
Vil's real-life twin for some people
being compared to karela de Ville of 101
Dalmatians isn't a compliment but we
have to hand it to this lady because
she's definitely giving karela run for
her money
the woman was photographed looking
exactly like the puppy obsessed villain
she has the same multi-coloured hair and
we even spot a bit of fur on the hood of
her winter coat Elsa's long-lost sister
there were many everyday people who
think they look like Elsa from the movie
frozen but we think this girl takes the
cake
she obviously thinks she looks a lot
like the frozen character - she took
this photo next to a cutout of Elsa and
we have to admit the resemblance is
uncanny they have the same facial
expression the same beautiful eyes and
the exact same smile all this girl needs
is a beautiful blue dress to really
transform her into the Disney star Khal
Drogo and scar how crazy is the
resemblance between Jason Momoa is Game
of Thrones character Khal Drogo and scar
from The Lion King the Warlord's tan
skin and dark hair and features really
resembles scars appearance even though
kal is human and scar is a lion that
doesn't change the fact that these two
are the spitting image of each other
don't you agree
do you know anyone who looks like a
real-life Disney character react in the
comments section down below and don't
forget to give this video a big thumbs
up
[Music]